is a good or bad to take iodine for cancer.
I know there's a book written probably 40 years ago
about using iodine for breast cancer.
I don't know if it's Dr. Brown's Steed
or somebody else who wrote that book.
And back probably in the 70s and 80s,
maybe 60, 70s and 80s,
nutritional therapists,
caripractors, naturopaths,
and nutritional people today,
a lot of Instagrammers and TikTok people,
what do you call those people?
Influencers push iodine heavily.
New research has come out
and it's not even new research.
It's maybe 20 years old.
That has showed that excess iodine
can be quite harmful for your thyroid gland.
Iodine is extremely attractive to your thyroid.
Your thyroid needs iodine,
part of the T3 and T4 hormone that your thyroid makes
is contains iodine.
So iodine is necessary nutrient for your thyroid.
However, both people will get enough iodine
in their diet to supplement everything and more
than what your thyroid needs.
Now years and years ago,
there used to be what's called the goiter belt.
That was the Midwest area
because in the Midwest in the soil,
we tend to have less iodine.
So people who don't have enough iodine
to have an iodine deficiency
can be more prone to goiters.
That was the data at the time.
So you may need iodine.
So they started adding potassium iodine to salt
because everybody eats salt.
So you can remember,
buying salt, nobody buys this salt anymore, do you?
You're buying pig salt, you're buying good real salt,
but the used to buy salt that was iodized salt.
And that's where you would get your iodine
to supplement for the needs of the thyroid gland.
Well, that has kind of been debunked
besides the fact that nobody is just only eating your vegetables
from your home grown garden
that the soil is deficient to iodine anymore.
You're getting food from all different sources
that's coming from all across the country and out of our country.
So there's a very few people that are deficient
in iodine.
Now you could measure that in a blood test
to see if you have iodine deficiency
and then you would be careful taking the amount
that you would take.
But a lot of the dishes still hold to the old theory
that everybody should be taking iodine
so they're taking iodine.
The problem is is that because iodine is so attractive
to the thyroid gland,
it can cause Hashimoto's really easy
which is an autoimmune thyroid.
So you do have to be careful with iodine.
It would not necessarily go and just jump in
and everybody take iodine.
You can measure that to see if you have a deficiency
and the skin topical ways of measuring,
meaning you put liquid iodine on your skin
and time how long it takes for you to absorb it
are not accurate.
I would not rely on that.
Get a blood test for a measuring iodine.
If you think you have a deficiency in iodine,
we just have not seed deficiencies in iodine
when you measure them.
So again, it's better to measure,
it's better to quantify before you just follow
an influencer.